you know what i love about your show is
uh first of all
i really enjoy you and i think you're a
terrific performer and then you've got
don johnson doing this with you who
one of the coolest people in my opinion
in the history of
television and then uh
the times that i've briefly gotten to
chat with him
he's such a nice guy don johnson
absolutely it's weird you know because
when i was growing up it was like him
stingray and mr t yes
coolest people on television you know
yeah like stingray and hawk
you know that was my like crockett in
tubs you know right for like right after
that
and then mr t was just the epic so when
i got a chance to facetime him i mean
within five seconds he was just as
chill as any dude could be and he was
just like i love the idea for the show
and blah blah blah and we talked about
like fatherhood and loud you know it's
just
an immediate bond i was like oh this guy
is the greatest
then once i started making him laugh and
figured out what his funny bone was
and let him tell stories and jokes and
stuff like that that make him laugh as
well it was just like
secreted in cement like that guy has one
of the greatest laughs
in the world does he ever tell stories
about miami vice
or is he yes yes
every day and it came up the other day
that he knew some
pretty intriguing drug lords over the
years oh yeah
because he was in miami i mean in the
80s
and that was the most popular show in
the world so don johnson's probably
meeting some pretty interesting
characters yeah he's got some great
stories and i'm glad he's on the other
side of it now in his later
years and he can just relax and tell
these stories but man they
are wild